so I'm there I see a group of attractive
ladies order Guinness you know I'm not
sure I don't know mother drink it chef
I'm not addressing up against but these
Guinness were purple they were purple
they're purple
yeah you were saying that on your
Instagram they were purple Guinness I
thought well that was [ __ ] delicious
I'll take three of those now I wasn't
awaiting no no they were they my
Instagram it looks I mean purple problem
I've seen Guinness Anastasia Bosley
consequence was purple Guinness those
look delicious three for me my mates and
this dude my me my dad my mate
so Hobbs come from Manchester right so I
like this grisly Irish man the I whose
family fall off the English in this bar
and it's been family owned forever
I said three purple Guinness sir because
are you sure I went yeah yes all right
give it to me I had no idea that I'm not
supposed to do that yeah so in other
words I mean you're a loyalist to the
British flag too I wish you something
cool like that class English so I could
get away with that
no it means you suck talk it means
you're certified Irish wait a minute I
heard what I don't hear oh dude you're
an I did you're an IDE are they came out
on my so axe yeah yeah crunch I'm and
that means you're an ID D it means you
you deep throat and swallow the gravy so
they have it they have a [ __ ] color
for the beer so you're sending a signal
to other guys yeah basically for I like
it's for chicks in space like live is
it's like ordered a piña colada I can
catch it because they take the Guinness
and I play black currently oh let me
tell you something though but I know you
got a sweet tooth so it was to do this G
teeth uh-huh
that [ __ ] was the best thing that's ever
hit my lips but I got roasted so bad on
line for it so bad
articles are written out there and write
your headlines articles were known out
there making fun of me really and at the
shows people would boo me and you know
what I'd come out on stage with a
Guinness like no no there's no it's not
purple it's not please I apologize every
show apologizing in fact I
I'm gonna start this off hey hey hey how
about a heads up though on some of the
little things in life well I should have
known because there's just chicks
ordering it it tastes like a black wine
gumbo it was so delicious
behind closed door I wish I could have
drank that [ __ ] man no black currant how
good was it though
delish okay so coach Winkeljohn said
that after cyborg fought Tonya Avenger
he found some holes in her game and he
thinks that Holly can take advantage of
those holes and win the fight against
cyborg perfect so it's a fight happen he
has a cyborgs like simple Holly Holm
doesn't turn down fights then Jackson
weak anime should let her fight AFC to a
nine
Holly's last four or five showed she's
beatable - yeah no [ __ ]
and then Clarissa shields mentioned
cyborg like going hey say what not on my
watch cyborg sister let me know when
you're ready to start preparing for I
got you yeah they love each other uh you
know Clarissa with her box and pedigree
might help bring them when holly has a
good boxing pedigree but her cake Boston
would be the issues for cyborg stylishly
its cyber toughest fight with yes she
walked through Holly how funny would be
in this weird fight world we live in in
off see Holly Merck Rhonda no does he
happen she goes on to lose what three in
a row and then she wins one right
that's Remo hand educated with a head
kick and then you know she kind of down
him out and then she knocked outside
burger the head kick then everything's
erased right shades well then she's
number one of our number one of all
times she get the easy salvage anything
she's ever done by beating side one does
it happen no I think I think Kali had a
better chance of beating Ronda than
she's a cyborg
not even close she has a way more
difficult task beating see I think cyber
is the best female fighter of all time
yeah but the tough to figure out you
want to take her down good luck
if you do go down and she's a black belt
her striking she hits like a man like so
much power confidence she find has the
belt at there's way more obstacles for
Holly to solve with cyborg and she had
with Ronda Ronda avoid
I'm bars kick in the [ __ ] face
sideboard over at left hand the right
hand don't get taken down don't get in
close don't let her get you down the
ground excuse the black ground jujitsu
she's great chin I've never seen a bring
beat there's not we haven't seen any
holes you know they say they've seen
holes but [ __ ] man that's a great fight
though yeah that should be taught us
Holly what do we do what do we do
Megan Anderson yeah I mean this is the
only women's fight that I would and
that's I would pay for side with Holly
mmm that's the best that's the best
fight in women's history history history
name a better one nothing more there's
nothing worse when that watch this when
you want to do exactly I'm sitting like
this they're going to they go like why
hate me like as they go they're talking
eyes well let me just are talking and
doing it oh God just crank yeah they say
that the condition people you know like
people chewing loud or people sipping
stuff I go crazy it triggers me so I
guess it's a condition do you know what
it is - there's a term for it people
they can't list another be like snack
food or slurp coffee I really I go crazy
trigger yeah it's a straight-up trigger
even my own daughter okay watch this to
my own daughter when she was like six
she would eat like it
and I go we shouldn't they're morning I
go huh
I love my daughter of it no no does it
again gotta help us out though too high
go you gotta keep it round close I am so
and I I would and I talk to there was
this like you have these parent meetings
yeah like about school and this one
woman goes you know I'm going to say
something and you know it's it's my
daughter twos and she makes this noise
and it drives me nuts and I actually
don't like her when she's chewing that's
food I start laughing so hard yeah for
me too for me it's a good like if I'm
out eating some like that and if Joe's
chewing out or something my dad I'm like
I I literally I I'll have to leave or
I'll have to say something my brother
came my room he's eating a whiny gum in
Dublin II checked off and I went dude so
he had a problem with me as a kid he
used to do it my dad and if you
want to get Jay to fight you just go cuz
he's to Duke my daddy says shush him
like oh yeah he'd be talking or eating
my [ __ ] kushma she was really cool
yeah and so if you got to Jay to trig
any like freaks out and stab people in
the face so um Jay used to do it and so
yo man he said it just bothered I don't
know what's the condition called whoo
yeah I have it to the 10th my father my
father when when you would be saying
stuff that he didn't agree with or that
was he considered you know stupid boy
you would be making a point he'd gone
okay let me let's try to III let let me
try to back you up
a little bit cool because I live in the
real world and obviously you're living
in a fantasy world but I will romance
you for a second I will roam it that
kind of show you I'd be like yeah